willkommen zur heutigen sitzung in der
wir uns mit den begriffen dem phänomen
der liebe nach augustinus und hannah
arendt befassen
es ist ein entspanntes thema auch nicht
ganz einfach
ich gehe noch mal auf dem plan des - ein
wir nähern uns mit großen schritten die
ende
in der letzten sitzung die leider nur
also die nachhinein stattfinden konnte
die aber auf youtube zu finden der sich
nach oben rechts im hatten wir es mit
zarten zu tun und seinem begriff des
hasses ich komme darauf gleich nochmal
zu sprechen der heutigen sitzung geht es
um liebe den ersten teil und die antiken
spätantiken wurzeln bei augustinus und
die interpretation durch eine art der
nächsten und letzten sitzung im semester
geht es um die liebe bei harry frankfurt
einem noch lebenden amerikanischen film
suchen der mit ganz interessante theorie
dazu entwickelt hat jetzt gebe ich noch
einen kurzen rückblick zu diesen mit dem
herren haben wir diese
existenzialistischen zweifeln
es ist schon konzerte und er hat ein
philosophisches hauptwerk geschriebenen
titel das sein und das nichts
es sind ja 1943 dieses werk ist auch
stark beeinflusst von heiliger auf den
wir ja auch schon zu sprechen kam als es
um sein begriff der angst gegen rechts
dazu die entsprechenden link sowas geht
es jetzt bei satire des hasses behandelt
und hass aus existenz philosophische
sicht genauso wie an auch den hass oder
bzw
ekel aus existenz wieder so für das
nicht behandelt hatte auch hier wieder
oben rechts der link zu den spitzen
zunge als ihm geht es immer meine
existenz philosophische analyse der
jeweiligen emotionen findest du
überhaupt eine ist
der hass gilt intentional also mit
seiner richtung mit seiner ausrichtung
nicht einer bestimmten eigenschaft die
man jetzt hast an jemand anderem sondern
der existenz des anderen als solche das
geht im harz nach sagte ebenfalls die
andere existenz die regiert wird oder
die zum anlass genommen wird sie zu
vernichten und nicht nur eine bestimmte
eigenschaft zu das ganze das ist
entscheidend
der hass gründet nach sartorius darin
dass der andere uns in seiner freiheit
überschreitet selber spricht von
transzendenz und für gegenständliche
also wir sind gewissermaßen das objekt
der freiheit des anderen seite
argumentiert jetzt dass wir diese für
gegenständliche durch die freiheit des
anderen nicht ertragen können und er
hasst ist das ein schwarzes gefühl ich
denke den würde jeder zustimmen
kommentiert damit bestimmt kein helleren
farben also es hat etwas sehr vernichten
dass dieses nichts das manifestiert sich
auch in der schwärze und er verweist
auch auf eine dialektik dabei besteht
das gegen hass den anderen gerade nicht
vollständig vernichten können sondern
wir ihnen immer anerkennen müssen
er ist ja das objekt des hauses und das
ende da diese idee schon herr knecht die
leute also der hass ist eine sehr
spannungsreichen angelegenheit jetzt
kann man sich natürlich weiter wie fern
ist entweder schön im hass so was wie
eine rationale dimension enthalten
ja das ist eine gute frage ist auf jeden
fall gerichtet auf bettlers als er hat
ein ganz klares objekt das kann man sich
fragen wird darin etwas urteilt oder
nicht nur gefühlt ich denke schon dass
jemand der ihr mandant hast dass du
immer gründe angeben kann warum diese
andere person hast jetzt ist natürlich
die frage
darin geht ja der hass nicht einer
bestimmten eigenschaft von der person
als solche das kann man sich fragen ob
in diesem fall der hat wirklich gründe
angeben kann wenn es um die andere
person als solche geht und ich nur
bestimmte eigenschaften das ist also
eine ganz spannende frage wir werden
darauf in der heutigen diskussion noch
näher darauf eingehen
jetzt komme ich aber noch mal auf die
leitfragen zu sprechen der heutigen
sitzung also wie fensterheber eine
emotion liefert enthält lieber eine
rationale einem internationalen und eine
phänomenale dimension gesagt beim hat er
hat auf jeden fall gezeigt dass er eine
phänomenale dimension hat nämlich so
dieses schwarze ich denke das trifft
diese gefühl seite des hauses gut die
motivation aale hat er bestimmt auch
gezeigt dass eben darum geht den anderen
zu vernichten
die rationale kam mir jetzt da noch ein
bisschen zu kurz vielleicht deswegen
weil sie trotz eines stark
existenzialistische perspektive einen
darüber müssen wir noch genauer
diskutieren wie verhalten sich liebe und
hass also ich denke schon dass wir jetzt
zu recht die liebe behandeln nachdem mit
den hass gehandelt haben
also auch hier ist die frage bitte liebe
konkreten eigenschaften oder gilt sie
nicht auch der person als solcher dann
interpretiert hannah arendt den augustin
ischen liebes begriff welche formen
familie unterscheidet anna haben sich
ausgezahlt augustinus das ist glaube ich
hier ganz wichtige frage weil wir
deutschen so ganz allgemein familie
besprechen aber die lateinische und
griechische antike ganz verschiedene
form von liebe kennt die wir alle unter
dem namen lieh befassen
da sind wir im deutschen nicht so ganz
differenziert wie es die antike war so
jetzt komme ich mal auf die beim hält
helden und heldinnen des heutigen der
heutigen sitzung zu sprechen also hier
auch das team aus ghana haben und das
ist ihre dissertation aus dem jahr 929
dieser damaligen zeit bei augustinus
ziemlich in mode
auch heiliger hat sich damit beschäftigt
diese schrift hat meine damaligen zeit
zu liest man nicht vielmehr acht hunde
von sie wurde sogar stark kritisiert
aber wir wollen jetzt heute mal ein
bisschen einlesen sie haben bestimmt
schon gemerkt bei der lektüre
das ist keine leichte schrift sie ist
etwas philologisch angehaucht hier
werden sehr viele lateinische und
griechische begriffe verwendet die uns
heute nicht unbedingt mehr verständlich
sind
ich bringe jetzt deswegen nur ein paar
zitate ich möchte jetzt das gar nicht
und aller ausführlichkeit behandeln also
sie sagt das ist jetzt die tat der armor
der innerhalb des irdischen lang etwas
sicheren strebt über das er verfügen
kann wird dauernd enttäuscht weil alles
der sterblichkeit verfallen ist
diese enttäuschen schlechte um und wird
ausschließlich negativ stimmt also arme
kennen wir schon als eine form der liebe
sie kennt in dieses engelchen was mit
einem fall die liebe entzündet das ist
ein begriff der liebe wir müssen doch
genauer schauen wir jetzt aber im
ausgang von augustinus den amor bestimmt
diesen falschen armut er sich an die
welt klammert und damit zugleich die
welt konstituiert das heißt wildlist
nennt augustinus coupe die tat es ist
die begierde den rechten anderer ist
anzahl stimmrechte aber die richtige
gedachte ewigkeit und absolute suchens
strikt nennt er caritas also es gibt
jetzt nach augustinus seine abend zwei
formen des am ort der liebe wir müssen
noch genauer bestimmt was meine von
beliebt ist
es gibt die ihre tische liebe oder
irgendwie schon begehren das richtet
sich nach dem sicheren was aber eben
auch vergänglich ist das objekt der
liebe es hier verdrängen
und es gibt den richtigen armut geben
nach die ewigkeit strebt die nicht
vergänglich ist hier sieht man schon
alle diese frage stellt sich wohl weil
das sagt jetzt aber dem ausgang von
augustinus der armor vermittelt zwischen
fans und erwartung als ammann ist das
lebende die lebende person und am markt
ist das geliebte objekt die geliebte
person
der mensch ist nie isoliert von seinem
amt unbeliebte blick sondern zu ihm
gehörig die begierde nach weltlichkeit
ist wirklich gehört zur welt der kopie
tus hat durch seine kubitza selber seine
vergänglichkeit entschieden wäre die
caritas vermöge der erstrebten
aeternitas selbst ewig wird also die
beziehung von liebenden oder liebe und
geliebten ist ganz wichtig weil das
geliebte objekt gewissermaßen immer
zurück wirkt auf die liebe oder
gegenliebe
also es geht eben darum dass wir nicht
war eine weltliche liebe eine begierde
entwickeln sind eine caritas die eben
immer diese ewigkeit mit einbezieht die
nicht verloren gehen kann so wie es eben
indischen und vergänglichen gefallen ist
das sind sind sehr einleuchtend
unterscheidungen und dann bringt noch
weitere in ihren text muss dich auch
noch eingehen werde
als sie sagt am ohr ist der apetito soll
das streben und caritas ist der bezug
zum zoomen bonn um den höchst gut also
caritas ist doch noch ein bisschen höher
gestellt nach augustinus
es gibt es noch die delegation das ist
der aus der caritas entspringende bezug
zu sich und der welt
ok immer auch wichtig der selbstbezug
jetzt hatte ich mich schon bei seite
gefreut können wir uns dann nicht auch
selbst hassen die war nur die rede vom
hass gegenüber dem anderen genau sagen
der liebe können uns nicht auch selbst
die man jetzt bringt sich hier
entsprechungen zum griechischen also
hamster heraus die ihr sinnliche liebe
die lektion ist die story griechisch das
ist auch so etwas wie freundschaft und
der familie also wie die die das meer
gesteht stellte die nicht mehr sinnlich
liebe und die caritas als die für hannah
arendt und augustinus höchste form die
agape die eben über diese in ewigkeit
dimension besitzt und es gibt auch noch
das hat mich noch hinzugefügt die armee
xxi die freundschaftliche liebe die im
griechischen auch filiale zeichnet wird
das kann man sich natürlich fragen ist
die philosophie ist dass die
freundschaft zur philosophie
das ist die große frage lauten würde das
verneinen würde sagen die philosophie
ist eine erotische beziehung
wie ist das zu verstehen indem sie post
von platon in dieser schriften sehr
empfehlenswert ist in diesem dialog ist
der eros die aufsteigende liebe die von
unten sich auch im verglich dann und die
agape ist hier die von oben herab sich
bewegende liebe die er dann dem
christentum in verbindung gesetzt wird
und er eröffnet er mit der antiken
philosophie in bezug gesetzt ja das sind
so die verschiedenen formen auf die alle
angeht kann man sich fragen
die gräfin ist jetzt liebe je nachdem
welche formen jetzt betrachtet
auch in die rational ist eine gewisse
urteil store enthalten
das muss man sich genau überlegen ich
denke man kann nicht ein einheitliches
info- sprechen wie es im deutschen eben
auf der fall ist sondern muss die
wirklich streng unterscheiden zwischen
mindestens vier formen arman t lektion
caritas und damit beziehen wir sehen
natürlich dass hier eine gewisse
vergeistigung stattfindet und in der
caritas denke ich kann man am nächsten
relationale struktur erkennen wir wollen
darüber dann weiter diskutieren ein
emotionales seite ist auf jeden fall im
enthalten und sicherlich am größten im
fall des am ohr oder er muss das ist
klar
eine motivation aale strukturen mit
sicherheit auch da hier eine ganz
starkes begehren ausgeübt wird nach
einem gewissen objekt und man kann sich
auf fragen und die liebe wirklich nur
eine emotion ist oder ob hier in der
liebe mich doch der emotionale bzw
der motivation aale respekt am größten
ist so dass die anderen beiden aspekte
der urteils aspekt und der gefühlsmäßig
es wird vielleicht ein bisschen zu kurz
kommt und in diese richtung argumentiert
auch hier in frankfurt in der nächsten
sitzung sehen werden er sagt die liebe
ist eigentlich eine qualifikation
unseres willens
es geht hier also stark um das wollen
das streben und nicht so sehr um das
urteilen oder um das fühlen
das ist eine frage die wir noch genauer
diskutieren wollen so in der nächsten
sitzung geht es eben gerade und diesen
begriff der liebe herr frankfurt und
jetzt wünsche ich allen zuschauern alles
gute bis zur nächsten sitzung